er ist rücksichtslos
genial - ein medienmagnat der ein
globales imperium im wert von mehr als
80 milliarden dollar show erlebt das
mediengeschäft er ist 24 stunden am tag
7 tage die woche damit beschäftigt er
isst schläft und trinkt es sind erfolg
in den medien kommt nicht so leicht und
schnell rupert murdoch von news corp ist
ein moderner presse baron herrscher über
zeitungen und zeitschriften
fernsehsender und kabelkanäle
filmstudios und satellitensystemen die
oft die botschaft ihres provokanten und
polarisierenden chefs widerspiegeln er
sendet seine redakteure wissen was
hubert will und setzen das auch gerne um
seit mehr als 50 jahren baut murdoch
sein reich stück für stück auf und löst
dabei feuer stürme der kontroversen aus
rupert murdoch ist die verkörperung des
bösen ist nicht mehr die angesehene
zeitung die sie einmal war uns einfach
bittere rivalitäten ziel es ist ein
zeitungs krieg es gibt immer jemanden
der sterben muss damit du lieben kannst
und rupert ist gut darin weil er mehr
schmerz ertragen kann als jeder andere
diese kämpfe führten sein unternehmen
von den höhen des erfolgs an den rande
des zusammenbruchs
und wieder zurück
huber geht es vor allem um macht man
könnte fast sagen er ist
größenwahnsinnig so viel besitzen so
viel einfluss haben wie er kann er will
der größte und beste sein den es je gab
oder geben wird
[Musik]
murdoch wurde schon als vieles
bezeichnet sogar in seinem eigenen
netzwerk ich bin rupert murdoch der
tyrannische milliardär und das ist meine
skybox wenn du rupert murdoch bist
beweise es
[Musik]
paradox präsenz in film fernsehen und
printmedien ist in fast allen teilen der
welt zu spüren
rupert murdoch ist das was gott meinte
als er einen medienmanager schuf wie er
hat alle eigenschaften die ein
medienmanager braucht er hat visionen er
hat nur wer geht risiken ein und er geht
an die grenzen
seines jährigen startete mit einer
kleinen zeitung in australien und wurde
zu einem der größten medienunternehmen
der welt mit über 150 zeitungen
internationalen fernsehsendern und einem
filmstudio in the movie studio die news
corporation hat einen jährlichen umsatz
von etwa 32 milliarden dollar der mann
der so viel von dem kontrolliert was wir
sehen wollte nicht von uns interviewt
werden wie es soweit hier obwohl er
seine politischen ansichten nie
versteckt hat ich würde sagen
unterstützt die bush politik im nahen
osten auch wenn wir es ein vorgehen sehr
kritisch gesehen haben oder seine
ambition ich extreme
rücksichtslose was er wollte und nichts
würde ihnen davon abhalten das zu
bekommen ich glaube das war
wahrscheinlich seine leben sein
markenzeichen der anfang und der kern
seines imperiums die zeitung
[Musik]
man ist im zeitungsgeschäft aufgewachsen
er hat er sein erfolg gefunden er liebt
das tagesgeschäft ich habe ihn eine
zeitung lesen sehen das ist ein
körperlicher art es ist so körperlich
mit einer frau liebe zu machen
diese besessenheit in seinen genen
rupert murdoch wurde am 11 märz 1931 als
sohn des prominenten zeitungsmann es
murdoch und seiner frau lady elisabeth
murdoch geboren er wuchs auf der
familienfeier außerhalb von melbourne
australien auf und besuchte
ich weiß nicht ob es mir gefallen hat er
nicht ich habe damals nicht darüber
nachgedacht aber die meisten sind
sicherlich glücklich aber er fühlte sich
fehl am platz und leben von den kindern
der melbourner elite andrew butscher
vizepräsident für
unternehmensangelegenheiten und
kommunikation bei news corp
einen privilegierten umfeld aber sein
vater besaß das unternehmen nicht in dem
er arbeitete
sich selbst immer als außenseiter er
biete darin auf das gab ihm einen
wettbewerbsvorteil
er muss sich noch weiter ab als er nach
oxford wo seine vorliebe für die
kommunistische philosophie ihm einen
spitznamen einbrachte
der rote ruppert
das war wohl das produkt seines
rebellischen geist ich bin sicher dass
er gegen seine eltern rebellierte wo er
konnte und gegen die werke seiner eltern
sowie die meisten jungen leute mango mit
canon war ein junger journalist in
australien der später mit murdoch
zusammenarbeitet ich glaube dass rupert
murdoch damals vor allem von dem wunsch
getrieben war dem ruf seines vaters
gerecht zu werden
es war eine angespannte beziehung sein
vater war ziemlich distanziert es war
schwer etwas freundliches aus ihm heraus
führte eine starke zuneigung zu seinem
vater und zu dem was er
aber entschlossen ihn stolz zu machen
im oktober 1952 als er an oxford
studierte dies erfuhr murdoch dass sein
vater im alter von 67 jahren an krebs
und herzproblemen gestorben war als er
nach hause zurückkehrte sah er wie seine
mutter von dem kollegen seines vaters
unter druck gesetzt wurde ihre zeit und
beteiligungen zu verkaufen hubert war
entsetzt wie seine mutter an und über
den mangel an raum
verkauf bedroht war unter anderem
ein boulevard blatt vor mit einer
auflage von nur 75.000
nach seinem abschluss in oxford ging
murdoch zurück nach australien und
übernahmen die kontrolle
schon bald hatte er seine finger in
allen unternehmensbereichen
er war extrem zu packen ich weiß aus
eigener erfahrung dass er die gleichen
redaktionellen fähigkeiten hatte wie
alle anderen
1958 machte er seinen ersten vorstoß in
ein anderes medium das fernsehen einem
kleinen
peter tschannen ist ehemaliger präsident
und chief operating officer
eines der dinge handeln sich die leute
nicht erinnern ist dass rupert schon
ende der 50er anfang der 60er jahre in
australien ein fernsehen es besser und
das ist eines der dinge die ihn hierher
brachten er hatte wiederholungsrechte
und fürs rechte ist von amerikanischen
studios und netzwerken gekauft
eine nationale zeitung zu gründen
man sagte ihnen das werde nicht
funktionieren die entfernung sei zu groß
und es gebe nicht genug nationale
werbung um das blatt aufrecht zu
erhalten man sagte ihnen er werde auch
kein personal finden weil kein guter
journalist für eine zeitung arbeiten
wolle die so eindeutig zum scheitern
verurteilt sei
die zeitung hatte von anfang an eine
liberale haltung und der verantwortliche
mann war immer präsent
rupert lief praktisch jeden abend im
büro auf und ab er ging dann spät abends
um 22 uhr gegen redaktionsschluss in der
zeitung herum meistens in so einem
leuchtend gelben regenmantel und wurde
gelegentlich von einem der mitarbeiter
die ihm nicht so gut kannten mit einer
reinigungskraft verwechselt
madox direkte kontrolle über seine
zeitungen
ich mische mich schon sehr in die
zeitungen ein aber ich glaube
andererseits was ich meinen redakteuren
auch große freiheiten im alter von 25
jahren heiratete murdoch und bekam eine
tochter prudence die er wurde nach elf
jahren geschieden
1967 heiratete er seine zweite frau erna
dorf mit ihr bekam er in den nächsten
fünf jahren drei kinder
lachen
wichtig ist es seine familie und seine
firma ich glaube das sind diese dinge
die in seinem kopf absolut miteinander
verbunden sein ähnliches man mit dem
alten wurden seine ansichten
konservative
wurde mehr und mehr zum gefangenen der
geschäftswelt in sydney
und wenn er in den yachtclub ging
machten sich die anderen immer über ihn
lustig und fragten nach wie geht es
deinem roten lampen voller zeitung
ruppert
rupert ist glaube ich vor allem an macht
interessiert
man könnte fast sagen er ist
größenwahnsinnig er möchte so viel wie
möglich besitzen soviel wie möglich
beeinflussen die größte und beste sein
den es je gab oder geben wird
ende der 60er jahre war rupert murdoch
auf einem anderen container gelandet und
in einem der wettbewerbsintensivsten
märkten der welt der definition des
alten establishment mit londoner fleet
street
wo er auf den berüchtigten
medienmagnaten rupert
murdoch fing an gegen seine bekannten
konkurrenten in den kampf
europas geschäftsstrategie als zeitungs
strategie betrachten es ist ein zeitungs
krieg es gibt immer jemanden der sterben
muss damit man leben kann
mit einem doppelschlag überlistete er
max will und kaufte die beliebten club
süchtige
und die schwächelnde tageszeitung
er belebte sie wieder baute sie in
kürzester zeit zu einem kraftwerk auf
die leser waren vor allem männer die
eine kombination wollten aus sport
sexskandalen außenpolitik und oben ohne
mädchen
beckett ist medienanalyst an der london
school of economics
release an ob man sie nun mag oder nicht
und millionen von menschen liebten sie
hat einen riesigen kulturellen einfluss
gehabt sowohl zum guten als auch zum
bösen sie hatte einen stil der die
öffentlichkeit für sehr reale themen
sensibilisiert hat und sie war natürlich
ein fantastischer kommerzieller erfolg
im visier die er erobern wollte amerika
hat sich in australien nie wohlgefühlt
braucht nicht in großbritannien aber kam
hier an und dachte sofort muss das ist
mein zuhause
[Musik]
1973 ließ sich murdoch mit seiner
familie in der wohlhabenden upper east
side
von new yorks erwies
er wollte expandieren aber um auf dem us
markt fuß zu fassen musste er sich mit
seiner kleinen regionalzeitung zufrieden
geben bergauf seine zeitung in san
antonio texas verkauft sie weil er sich
leisten kann
als nächstes wollte murdoch eine
nationale prinz es also gründete er eine
zeitung ist da um gegen den reißerischen
national enquirer schogur
da hat es schwer zu erscheinen
oliver zeitungen werden in amerika in
supermärkten verkauft wie das heißt wir
müssen für frauen das war nie ein
richtig erfolgreich das extreme
trotzdem verkaufte er später einen
aufgeputschten star für 400 millionen
dollar angeben muttergesellschaft des
national enquirer
war es ein verlassen des liberales
boulevardblatt seine fantasie beflügelt
die new york post die er 1976 für 30
millionen dollar
wenig später erwarb er gegen den
widerstand der arbeitnehmer das new york
magazine für 75 millionen
inklusive der liberalen wird wo es ist
schwer sich eine publikation
vorzustellen weniger zu rupert murdoch
passt als du village voice
boys warf einen ansehnlichen gewinn ab
jahre später verkaufte murdoch sie für
55 millionen dollar
murdoch war jetzt auch im plan in new
york im januar 77 schmückte er das
titelblatt des time magazine service
king kong der über der stadt thront nach
den einflussreichsten blättern greift
locations darunter auch die post
martin singer men ist ehemaliger
herausgeber
die zeitung lag im sterben wenn man so
will rupert murdoch investierte in das
blatt sowohl finanziell als auch
personell
anderthalb jahre später investierten wir
in neue druckmaschinen um der zeitung
farbe zu geben
seiten hin zu und machten alles was man
tun würde um der zeitung mehr substanz
zu geben
lebte die zeitung mit aufsehenerregenden
schlag sein
inhalt
kombiniert und klatsch und tratsch sport
gucken spielen
zeitungen verkaufen sich über
schlagzeilen aber langfristig müssen sie
auch substanz haben die leute kaufen sie
nicht wenn sie sie einmal angeschaut
haben und nichts finden es ist also
wirklich ein zweistufiger
finanziell war sie eine katastrophe und
verlor jedes jahr millionen von dollar
ich glaube nicht dass es rupert unter
dem strich nur darum geht zu gewinnen
ihm gefällt der gedanke dass er dadurch
einen platz am tisch bekommt dass er
seine position nach außen tragen kann
dass er zugang zu politikern bekommt
baut tischen
rupert murdoch ein wichtiger akteur
er beteuerte seinen redakteuren große
freiheiten einzuräumen aber diese
botschaft kam nicht immer bei den
mitarbeitern an
die story ist diktierte die geschichten
hubert war einfach überall
jemand sagte zu ihm ist der mörder da
gibt es einen widerspruch
sie sagten dass sie ihren redakteuren
erlauben die zeitung zu leiten und er
sagte das ist kein widerspruch
ich kenne bloß die redakteure die ich
einstelle
es geht wird und dann gibt es die leute
unterstellt gern leute ein die ihm
dankbar dafür sind dass er/sie
eingestellt hat solche auf deren
loyalität erzählen kann das stellt nicht
gerne leute ein die mit ihm konkurrieren
kathryn die das gefühl haben könnten
dass sie auf der gleichen ebene stieg er
in die kontrolle die er über seine
nachrichtenorganisationen ausübt besteht
nicht wirklich daran dass er ins telefon
schreit
man hat eher das gefühl dass seine
redakteure wissen was er will und dass
sie das gerne umsetzen
was rupert wolff zeigte sich schon bald
in einer jahrzehntelangen
1981 kaufte er die angesehene times und
die sunday times in london zurück in den
staaten holte er sich den borsten harris
und die chicago sun-times und wurde
erneut mit einer revolte vier topmanager
der sun times haben ihren rücktritt
erklärt darunter verleger james und der
kolumnist micro hat sich beurlauben
lassen
ich würde nie für seine zeitung arbeiten
nicht in new york nicht in washington
nicht in san antonio das ist schon
1985 kaufte the twentieth century fox
ein geschäft von zentraler bedeutung
denn es ist ein crossover er ist ein
mann der im verlagswesen tätig ist und
jetzt ein filmstudio kauf
250 millionen für eine 50 prozentige
beteiligung an dem studieren
es war schwierig die ersten 50 prozent
von davis zu kriegen aber dann bekam er
die anderen 50 prozent für schlappe 325
dollar
und so übernahme das gesamte filmstudio
twentieth century fox ist eine multi
milliarden schwere anlage für eine halbe
milliarde dollar
[Musik]
er hat mir mal gesagt dass die filme den
ersten kürzel sind dann braucht den
nervenkitzel wenn man den rest des
medienimperiums schon hat er braucht sie
weil auf diese weise kreative leute in
das unternehmen kommen
vor allem riskanten multi millionen
dollar films
der großartigsten dinge ist dass er in
einer krise der coolste und ruhig ist
und
wenn er dich unterstützt und hat mich
glaubt wird er immer hinter dir stehen
wenn er an und du ehrlich zu ihnen sind
von der angemessen halb seiner
entscheidung überzeugt ist er der beste
mann den du dir in einem schützengraben
murdoch wollte sein unternehmen
erweitern indem er sich in den us
fernsehmarkt
aber da gab es ein ernsthaftes problem
es gibt eine vorschrift dass man
staatsbürger der vereinigten staaten
sein muss um einen fernsehsender zu
besitzen und ruwer der pragmatiker
beschloss wenn das nötig ist werde ich
eben us-bürger
85 oder rupert murdoch amerikanischer
stoff
ist ehemaliger vorstandsvorsitzender von
british airways und ein enger freund
als murdoch seine australische
staatsbürgerschaft aufgab um die
amerikanische aufzunehmen wurde er dafür
kritisiert aber das unternehmen war nun
mal dort und der größte markt ist in den
usa
es ist nicht so dass er die
amerikanische staatsbürgerschaft nur
angenommen hat um dort ein medienraum zu
sein er hat sich entschieden sein leben
in amerika zu verbringen
er bezahlte john logie von metro media
bis zu 2 milliarden dollar im
fernsehsender in sechs russen
nbc cbs und es gab keinen platz für ein
weiteres netzwerk
twitter her und starb ein viertes
netzwerk
er sah dass es einen großen spüren für
netzwerk gab das jüngere zuschauer
anzieht und eine größere vielfalt
aber aus dem hochkarätigen debüt oder
ein schwerer fehlschlag
das ist die peep taste wir gehen live
drauf und das heißt kein piep
scheiterte kläglich gegen den
unerschütterlichen johnny castle für das
junge team box eine bittere lektion
das ncs der ehemalige präsident
seit den 50er jahren hatte niemand mehr
eine senderkette gegründet wir mussten
erst mal herausfinden wie ein network
sein muss dass sich von nbc und cbs
unterscheidet sonstwie nachhinein
scheint es offensichtlich oh ja wenn du
endest wenn cbs sendet dann wirst du
keinen erfolg haben
machte sich daran tochter länder zu
gewinnen die serien schöpfer des buchs
uns diesen kann es gab kreative freiheit
und sicherlich mehr als sie bei den
anderen networks bekommen würden aber
wir haben auch größere aufträge wir
setzten direkt auf serien weil wir das
mussten wir hatten ja nur ein jahr zeit
um das ganze aufzubauen und zum laufen
zu bringen
mit einer reihe von sendungen die sich
gegen die konkurrenz durchsetzen begann
der vierte sender sich in den
einschaltquoten zu wachen
[Musik]
jump street jankowski mary children and
family show ich meine der arbeitstitel
von mary children war nicht die kospi
und living colour all diese dinge wurden
viel mehr es muss einfach anders sein
als die sachen auf den anderen kanälen
und nichts war so anders wie die sendung
die alles verändern sollte der größte
wendepunkt waren die simpsons
blut hat hat es über alles geliebt den
sendeplan zu erstellen er war wie ein
kind in einem süßwarenladen und ich hab
immer witze darüber gemacht war dass er
aufsprang und an pfingsten an die tafel
zu machen sich zu fragen wie es das und
wie ihr mann na ja nicht so richtig gut
dann hängt er etwas anderes hin aber
irgendwann sprang auf und nahm die
simpsons und stellte sie am
donnerstagabend gegen die cosby show er
wollte diese winzige kleines änderungen
der wir gerade erst angefangen hatten
gegen die nummer eins im fernsehen
antreten lassen und zuerst dachten wir
ehrlich gesagt alle er sei verrückt wir
sagen das können wir nicht machen wir
werden vernichtet und er sagt wir immer
wieder raus vertraut mir das wird
funktionieren was liegen war zu
einhundert prozent pa cd jahren murdoch
ins amerikanische fernsehen expandierte
er löste er in london eine revolte der
mächtigen britischen presse gewerkschaft
das sollte die hauptstadt der zeitungen
sein und all die arbeit ist durch die
aktivitäten der londoner gewerkschaften
verloren gegangen um die
zeitungsproduktion zu automatisieren
legte murdoch sie von der fleet street
in ein wert im londoner viertel
das neue effiziente wer braucht er
weniger arbeitskräfte über 5000 liegen
murdoch plante sie alle zu entlassen
als ehemalige generalsekretärin der
britischen drucker gewerkschaft
verhandelte baroness brender die murdoch
in arbeitsplätze zu retten
das tier war verständlicherweise der
meinung dass er nicht mit den alten
arbeitspraktiken aus der fleet street
sein neues werk umzieht dass diese alten
nicht
was er wollte das war ein extrem
radikales abkommen unternehmen hat aber
das wird er nicht bekommen wir waren
immer noch bereit zu verhandeln und er
hörte zu und sagte am ende ein heli
musik hat sich geändert aber der tanz
bleibt
was brender die nicht wusste war dass
murdoch bereits eine geheime abmachung
mit der elektriker gewerkschaft
getroffen hatte um schnell mit einer
probe druckauflage voranzukommen
und deine kurs von sweeney als wir das
erfuhren als wir wussten was sie einen
probelauf durch hilfe versagt sich als
generalsekretärin erst mal zu unseren
leuten statt auf streik heute
[Musik]
murdoch bekam unterstützung von einer
alten freundin margaret thatcher die das
management den gewerkschaften vorzug er
hatte sie unterstützt als sie als
premierministerin kandidierte und das
zahlte sich aus
/ us regierung erliess gesetze und in
diesem internationalen nachrichten
streit im walking streit wie bekannt
wurde wurde die sogenannte
gewerkschaftlich gesetzgebung zu einem
schlüsselfaktor für das rupert murdoch
tausende kamen um die proteste zu
unterstützen aber die demonstrationen
nahmen eine gewalttätige window
[Applaus]
shopping wurde die festung genannt
wirklich alle war es gab
sicherheitsvorkehrungen es wurde eine
murdoch miliz ausgerufen er wurde
dämonisiert
es gab ziemlich schreckliche sachen ich
habe gesehen wie ein hat meiner
mitglieder von der polizei verprügelt
wurden wurde gewalt angewendet
wir versuchten das rekonstruieren können
manchmal konnten wir sonntag wir können
mit hilfe von zetsches zerschlug murdoch
die gewerkschaften und sein werk in
woking balls auf dem formen
aber er hat am ende
einige der den arbeit in den räten brach
es war ein bahnbrechender moment nicht
nur in der geschichte der arbeiterschaft
sondern in der geschichte
dass es nicht vernünftig dass es nicht
logisch der fortschritt verlangt dass
die regeln ändern
und murdochs einkaufstouren weißer
interniert
1988 kaufte er für drei milliarden
dollar das einen berg magazin imperium
mehr gesehen empire zudem auch racing
vormund
murdoch schockierender preis war der
größte der je für ein verlagshaus
gezahlt wurde doch dann wurde er durch
vorschriften gestoppt
der besitz einer zeitung und eines
fernsehsenders in einem einzigen markt
waren untersagt murdoch war gezwungen
seine beliebte in new york post zu
verkaufen
jahre später konnte er sie für 25
millionen dollar zurückkaufen nachdem er
eine sondergenehmigung erhalten
die post am leben erhalten weil er sie
am leben erhalten wollten niemand sonst
in der news corporation heute dass die
leute sehen bei der post arbeit
macht wirtschaft
unvermindert griff murdoch wortwörtlich
nach dem himmel
groß war das satellitenfernsehen
das fernsehen zu starten gegen eine hoch
finanzierte etablierte plattform namens
kritisch satellite broadcasting
einem der größten player aller zeiten
das trieb das unternehmen fast in den
bankrott
das lautet die explosion des fernsehens
in ganz europa und dem rest der welt ein
unternehmen
bietet seiner investition
wie sky blutete aus und murdoch hatte
sich durch seine kauf orgien bei den
gläubigern gefährlich verschuldet
glücklicherweise beschlossen 145 banken
um mehr zeit zu geben
eine bank in pittsburgh weigerte sich
jedoch und drohte einen kredit von 10
millionen dollar hin zu fordern hierzu
der park den r mit den banken
geschlossen hatte bestand darin dass
wenn eine bank den kredit einforderte
alle anderen kredite auch fällig wurden
mit einem anruf bei der bank in
pittsburgh rettete murdoch sein
unternehmen vor dem zusammenbruch
das waren diese unglaubliche leistung
mit der es geschafft hat das unternehmen
zu retten er musste teile davon
verkaufen magazine er musste sich zur
besseren geschäftspraktiken verpflichten
die banken sagten ihm er müsse sich
benehmen
er musste fast acht milliarden dollar
schulden umstrukturieren das war eine
nahtoderfahrung für sein unternehmen
vorher musste immer alles ganz schnell
gehen
operierter
noch 1993 war er zurück am pokertisch
milliarde dollar für den chinesischen
fernsehsenders speedtv aus
porta bist ein amerikanischer medien
analyst und verleger
nach china durch star ist das
satellitenfernsehen dass er in hongkong
aufbaute
dadurch hatte er in den frühen 90ern
breiten zugang zu einem medienmarkt dem
rest der westlichen länder im grunde
verschlossen war
am ersten september 93 erspielte er
diesen zugang murdoch hielt eine rede in
london die die chinesische regierung
entzog
die fortschritte in der
telekommunikations technologie haben
sich als eindeutige bedrohung für
totalitäre regimes erwiesen überall die
chinesin schlugen zurück indem sie den
privaten besitz von satellitenschüsseln
verboten und damit auch murdochs zugang
zu millionen haushalten partie war unter
beschuss
doch musste die chinesische regierung
besänftigen zur nahmen die ungeliebte
bbc vom sender und vernichtete einen
china kritisches buch des ex gouverneurs
von rom
die chinesische führung war besänftigt
und
murdoch vor vor ort chinesische beamte
zu umwerben dies um die präsenz von news
corp in china aus zwei präsenz in china
scheine in china ist die neue welt ist
es die zukunft und er hat das früher
erkannt als die meisten anderen aber
fast nichts funktioniert in china sein
konkurrent war die chinesische regierung
hat mit der chinesischen regierung kann
er nicht
konkurrieren doch ist kein großer
sportfan
doch in der firma 93 nahm er eine
amerikanische obsession
football und er traf mit einem
atemberaubenden angebot von über
anderthalb milliarden dollar schnappte
er sich die rechte an den national von
cbs
ich glaube nicht dass wir jemals einen
deal gemacht haben bei dem wir am
nächsten morgen nicht mit
gewissensbissen aufgewacht sind aber das
ist eigentlich gut denn es sportlich am
noch härter zu arbeiten über gerade für
die nfl hätte das ein großer fan sein
können
die football liga war sehr mutig fans
fox hatte nichts keine sportabteilung
es wird zwar wir sollten froh sein ich
habe dort gesehen wir sind vor sport
singular sie sind ein riesiges risiko
eingegangen was würden sie tun wenn sie
es verlassen wenn unsere show vor dem
spiel ein scherbenhaufen gewesen wären
wenn das set auseinander gefallen wäre
und dann wenn die übertragung beginnt
wir die touchdowns verpassen wir haben
es nicht drauf die ansager liegen falsch
und was wäre wenn er nicht alle
amerikaner erreichen würde die football
lieben murdoch zuckt nicht mit der
wimper er investierte weitere 500
millionen dollar in new world
communication
aus dem versierten investor ronald
koeman gehörte pollmann wechselte
daraufhin mit zwölf seiner wichtigsten
fernsehsender zuvor
es war die grösste sender umstellung in
der geschichte des us teams
und ein glücksfall für die lokalen wenn
die nfl auf volkstümlich über 900
millionen dollar ein und hat bis zu 20
millionen zuschauer die woche news
murdoch war auf dem aufsteigenden ast
wollte hand zu seinen wurzeln
zurückkehren er fand sich in der
fernsehbranche wieder die er gar nicht
mag ich glaube er hat nie eine volle
stunde fernsehen zur hauptsendezeit
gekonnt aber er mag das
nachrichtengeschäft mitte der 90er jahre
wollte murdoch den einzigen 24-stündigen
nachrichtensenders cnn kaufen aber
dessen eigentümer ted turner verachtet
für murdochs politik hat seine ansprüche
und das beruhte auf gegenseitigkeit
sondern verkaufte cnn schließlich
widerwillig so clm aber nicht an murdoch
1996 ging der sender im rahmen einer 75
milliarden dollar fusion mit turner
broadcasting am 2
murdoch musste sich etwas anderes
einfallen lassen er ließ sich nicht
beirren und gründete seinen eigenen
sender um sich mit cnl zum es
etablierte sich schnell als bühne für
konservative ansichten
ein teil des geschäftsplans ist man
sollte nicht mit ihnen konkurrieren
orion sollte sich um das grundwasser
sorgte publikum bemüht und man sollte so
machen dass es billiger ist als reporter
in die ganze welt zu schicken
kommentatoren und das funktionierte
robert ist von natur aus konservativ
vielleicht nicht so konservativ wie
james aber ihm gefiel die tatsache dass
roger einen plan für fox news hatte fox
hatte zu beginn viel geld verloren
rupert musste sogar kabelanbieter
bezahlen damit sie zu übernehmen
kontrovers und machte
amerikaner und auch die ausländischen
verbündeten die aktiv gegen unser
militär arbeiten sobald der krieg
begonnen hat betrachte ich als
staatsfeinde
mit dem slogan fair und ausgewogen
besteht der ehemalige präsident und coo
von news corp peter turner darauf dass
fox news einen unterschied zwischen
nachrichten und talkshow the talk shows
es gibt nachrichten bei fox news die
tatsächlich sehr neutral und ohne rad
und fair präsentiert werden und dann
gibt es tag und meinungs- shows von
denen niemand behauptet dass ihr
nachrichten
oder sean hannity sind eindeutig leute
auf der rechten seite des spektrums sie
wurden aber auch immer als solche
präsentieren
profitabelsten kabel nachrichtensender
in
murdochs privatleben braut sich etwas
zusammen
1999 ließ er sich nach 32 jahren von
seiner frau anna scheiben mit einer der
größten und abfindungen der geschichte
und der 68 jährige murdoch heiratete
direkt die 30 jährige wendy dank einer
absolventin der yale school of
management und ehemalige vize
präsidentin von star tv murdochs
persönliches leben schien wieder in
ordnung zu sein roger war weniger als
ein jahr später wurde bei ihm
mit 70 jahren kam er seine tochter grace
und mit 72
2003 im alter von 72 jahren rupert
murdoch auf eine weitere fernseh trug
er wollte schon seit einem jahrzehnt
er verhandelte fast zwei jahre lang mit
dem vorstand von general motors
irgendwann verkauften sie widerwillig an
directv
66 milliarden dollar angebot sich hatte
ihm einen anteil von 34 eine bizarre
kette von ereignissen zwang ihm nur ein
jahr später dazu ihn wieder aufzugeben
während er 2004 die wiederwahl von
george bush feierte übersah murdoch dass
ein riesiges aktienpaket seines
unternehmens news corp in australien auf
den markt
als sie in den amerikanischen markt
übertragen
rupert wachte eines morgens auf und
sagte heiliger bimbam dieser typ besitzt
16 meines unternehmens
er weiß ja dass john malone ein cleverer
geschäftsmann ist balance anteil an news
corp warum derzeit größte nach murdochs
um diesen anfang an seinem unternehmen
zurück zu bekommen musste rupert etwas
von erheblichem wert abgeben um john
malone los zu werden musste er diesen
anteil schließlich gegen directv
eintauschen ich glaube er wollte
vielleicht an directv festhalten das war
inzwischen ein wirklich starker
programmanbieter und robert hatte keinen
nationalen vertrieb das hätte ihm
wahrscheinlich gefallen
nachdem er seine aktien zurück gewonnen
hatte kaufte murdoch 2005 die
internetplattform myspace
er zahlte einen hohen preis um einen
konkurrenten auszustechen
diesmal für aixtron von
seiner sicht eine tragisch komische oder
myspace das war weisen sie tauchte erst
für
ich glaube etwas mehr als 500 millionen
dollar ich glaube einem zeitpunkt da
wurde sogar auf 25 milliarden geschätzt
jetzt war es
stellt also kehrte murdoch auf bekanntes
terrain zurück und richtete seinen blick
auf eine der angesehensten zeitung
und war früher reporterin bei der
zeitung als ich mit leuten über murdoch
und seine vorliebe für das wall street
journal sprach sagten sogar seine kinder
sie könnten sich an keine zeit erinnern
in der er nicht über die zeitung
gesprochen hätte das wall street journal
und die muttergesellschaft dow jones
waren im besitz der beiden kraft einer
prominenten boss der familie
hat schon dreimal versucht das wall
street journal zu kaufen
auf eine unglaublich hoch
zum ersten mal von dem zerwürfnis in der
bancroft familie erfuhr der die zeitung
seit über 100 jahren gehörte wetzte er
schon die keine
nutzte den moment und machte ein angebot
die aktie wurde für 36 dollar gehandelt
murdoch droht stolze 60 dollar
jay ist ehemaliger vize präsident und
direktor von bak
ich erinnere mich genau ich war
geschockt enttäuscht darüber dass man
journalismus mit dem unternehmen enden
würde für dass ich hart gearbeitet hatte
um gute ausgaben für das wall street
journal zu machen ist und dass sie von
einem mann übernommen wird den ich nicht
wirklich bewunderte
das schwindelerregende angebots spaltet
da waren jetzt kinder die drohten ihre
eltern zu verklagen wenn sie an murdoch
verkaufen
ich dachte es würde dem ansehen des wall
street journal schaden wenn er die
journalistischen prinzipien anwendet die
er ja fast sein ganzes leben lang
verfolgt hat nämlich seine feinde
anzugreifen seine freunde zu
unterstützen und politiker zu
unterstützen die ihm zu vorteilen
verhelfen könnten
doch versprach die qualität der zeitung
zu erhalten und die mitarbeiter zu
übernehmen
unabhängig bleiben ich sag nichts mehr
ich habe gesehen dass er den eigentümern
immer mehr versprechen gemacht und sie
dann gebrochen hat er versprach würde
die standard der times of london beide
halten und an dem redakteur harry evans
festhalten und innerhalb eines jahres
hatte evans gefeuert
also gaben die bank hofft nach am ersten
august 2007 schloss dow jones --eine
vereinbart
[Musik]
ich habe seine aufregung mitbekommen
dass jalloh gekauft hat dieses enorme
gefühl der befriedigung und er dachte
über sein leben nach er wird
wirklichkeit mit diesem verbringen
nicht jeder war so begeistert sein
wir sind heute hier um allen zu sagen
dass sie wissen sollten dass rupert
murdoch das wall street journal gekauft
hat wenig überraschend brach murdoch
bald seine versprechen und holte seine
eigenen leute ein
es gelang ihnen sozusagen durch die
hintertür die kultur mit einem schlag
kaputt zu machen und das ego der leute
die beim wall street journal arbeiteten
anzukaufen
doch magath überraschte viele seiner
kritiker das wall street journal
überholt
und wurde zur nummer eins der
tageszeitungen in amerika
rupert murdoch der löwe im winter wurde
2011 80 jahre alt nach 60 jahren in der
spitze eines medienimperiums stellte
sich die frage wer ihm nachfolgen würde
ich glaube er freut sich auf den tag an
dem seine drei kinder die sich für das
unternehmen interessieren gemeinsam für
ihn arbeiten er freut sich auf den tag
an dem es rupert mal vier gibt dort
kaufte die fernsehproduktionsfirma shiny
seiner tochter elisabeth
700 millionen dollar intesa sonova
gleichen kehrte nach einer erfolglosen
karriere bei news corp nach australien
zurück um den sender tvc einzuleiten
wurde stellvertretende geschäftsführer
news corp wir sind sehr
wettbewerbsorientiert und zwar in dem
maß dass wir dort wo wir marktanteile
gewinnen müssen diese auch erobern
werden dieser wettbewerbsgeist sickerte
in die unternehmenskultur ein
medien enthüllten dass die
boulevardzeitung news of the world die
sprachnachrichten eines jungen
mordopfers und ihrer familie ab
und die polizei für informationen
bezahlt
lewis war anfangs wurde das als ein
weiterer kleiner schmutziger skandal
eine journalistin angesehen die mit
privatdetektiven zu weit gegangen waren
aber was wir für einen relativ
begrenzten skandal hielten entpuppte
sich als ein allgegenwärtiger
systematischer missbrauch
journalistischer macht
auch die handys von prominenten und
politikern wurden gehackt so fragt
stellte sich heraus dass dieses telefon
hacking weit verbreitet war dass es
praktisch mit jedem gemacht wurde der
die möglichkeit bot nachrichten oder
klatsch
um den skandal einzudämmen wurde die 168
jahre alte news of the world im juli
2011 geschlossen
murdoch entschuldigte sich vor einem
britischen parlamentsausschuss
ich möchte nur eins sagen dies ist der
demütigste tag meines lebens seine
mitarbeiter hätten ihnen über das
hacking in die irre geführt
leute denen ich vertraut habe ich sage
nicht mehr und ich weiß nicht wie oft
sie mich im stich gelassen haben aber
sie haben sich schändlich verhalten und
das unternehmen und mich verraten
mitten in der anhörung versuchte ein
demonstrant murdoch mit einer torte
anzugreifen seine frau wendy beschützten
der skandal war schädlich und kost
spielen
james der erbe trat als vorsitzender von
gysi zurück und news corp zahlte über
380 millionen dollar an rechtskosten und
vergleichszahlungen zwei jahre nachdem
wendi murdoch ihren mann verteidigt
hatte ihm reichte rupert murdoch die
scheidung ein
er rief von sports network ins leben um
mit ihr spm zu konkurrieren rund um die
aktionäre zu besänftigen spaltete
murdoch im juni 2013 seien sechs
jahrzehnte als das verlagsgeschäft vom
rest des medienimperiums
das neue unternehmen nimmt heute
offiziell den handel auf es ist bereits
der größte zeitungsverlag der
vereinigten staaten mit einem marktwert
von 8,8 milliarden dollar
rupert murdoch ist ein riesiges und
vielfältiges imperium aufgebaut eine
konkurrenzlose und unaufhaltsame
zentrale der macht dies ist ein mann der
sowohl in wirtschaftlicher als auch in
politischer und kultureller hinsicht
außerordentlich mächtig ist
[Musik]
das charakteristische an ihm was ihn zu
einem presse baron macht ist dieses
ständige streben nach mehr und mehr
macht fest und das ist es auch woran wir
uns erinnern werden
guten wie im schlechten
[Musik]